hello everyone and welcome to a really
really wild game that was played in 1889
between emmanuel alaska
and sergey ivanovich palmer now uh
probably you've heard of las cruz he's
the
second official uh fide world chess
champion and
uh he was not the world champion when
this game was played he became world
champion some five years after this game
uh but he's facing a most unusual
opponent and this is a simultaneous
exhibition
uh so alaska is playing multiple
opponents here and uh
of course he he doesn't really think
much of his opponent and alaska was some
21 years of age here
whereas his opponent palmer was 28 uh
but i i couldn't find any photos where
they were
uh really young so a few words uh about
sergey vanovich paulner
as uh like i said i remember when i was
uh
reading some chess books long long time
ago and i uh saw this game
i was really amazed by it but i had no
idea who this gentleman was and i had no
idea that it was actually played in
a simultaneous exhibition game so uh it
i will put a link in the description
below the first link you see
uh will lead you to a very nice article
about sergey here so you can read a
little bit more about him
but uh just a few words so uh he was
born in orienbaum in 1861
he was exiled from the ussr in 1922
and ended up in germany he became a
professor of mathematics
at the russian gymnasium in berlin
headed the financial department
at the vataga publishing house then
moved to paris where he died
on july 13 1929 so
uh that's uh that's a little bit info
about this gentleman in short now
let's check out this game and do why
it's so so impressive so alaska has the
white pieces as one usually does when
holding a simultaneous exhibition
and opens with e4 uh we have e5 bipolar
uh knight to c3 that's not a knight uh
sorry about that the last screw goes for
the
for the vienna game knight c3 and now
knight to f6 we have g3 by alaska
uh and knight to c6 and bishop to g2
we have bishop to c5 and now knight g to
e2 preparing the castle
and this is all still uh being played
today so
uh these two know what they're doing so
d6
preparing to develop the light square
bishop uh and now h3 taking away the g4
square from black's pieces
bishop to e6 and now knight to d5 and
the knight
is on an excellent square here you
cannot trade knight for night because
then you just lose a piece
uh so here uh a lot of moves are
possible for example some of the more
popular moves today
are queen to d7 even bishop to d7 then
preparing to
capture knight with knight but uh in
those days
uh paulner just captured bishop captures
uh on d5 uh
and it's as of move seven the
disposition has never been reached again
we have pawn captures on d5 and knight
to e7 with a double attack on the d5
pawn so alaska
strengthens uh his presence in the
center he plays c4
and queen to d7 developing the queen now
uh kingside and queenside castles are
possible
and alaska strikes in the center with d4
now we have e captures knight captures
now getting uh
uh his his other knight in the center of
the board and now
uh paulner just castles with castles by
lasker
and now knight to f5 and here he's
offering a trade of knights of course he
wants to get his queen
uh to a more active square and alaska
should not uh
capture this night but it's a
simultaneous exhibition game and alaska
doesn't really
obviously think much of his opponent so
he just goes for it with knight captures
queen captures
and bishop to d2 now preparing to shift
the bishop over to c3 to transfer it to
this long diagonal
and now knight the e4 and now this uh
f2 pawn is attacked three times and you
really shouldn't allow that here alaska
should just play
something like bishop capture sunny four
queen captures and then offer a queen
trade maybe
and uh continue playing this game
however alaska just played king to h2
thinking that he will be able to uh well
take advantage of
uh this uh whole rook and queen action
going on on the f file
so uh paulner captures knight captures
on f2
and now the queen is under attack so
queen to b3 now
going after the b7 pawn and like i said
the knight cannot move as
you would uh simply lose the queen so
queen h5 unpinning
but it's very unclear what the queen is
actually doing on h5 so here
uh lasko should definitely go queen f3
try and trade off queens and say okay
i'm down upon i'm going to try and uh
hold this end game i i am lasker after
all
however lasker wants uh wants to win all
of the games he goes queen captures on
b7
uh and then now comes uh well now comes
rook a to b8 attacking last chris queen
lasker grabs another pawn and now
rook captures on b2 and now finally
lasko brings his bishop over to c3
attacking the rook and putting pressure
on the g7 pawn
however the position is now completely
lost for lasker
so uh feel free to pause the video and
win this game for lasker
uh well while i give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it there are actually two check
mating patterns uh
uh happening here uh and both of them
are uh
a forced check made in three sequence so
we're gonna first show the one that
did not uh happen in this game and
that's knight the g4
check so congratulations to everyone who
founded that uh now of course you cannot
capture you have to go back
king to h2 and now a nice queen
sacrifice queen
captures on h3 with check only move is
the bishop has to capture the queen
because this bishop covers the g1 square
captures and then rook the h2 is of
course checkmate again bishop covers g1
the king has nowhere to go
so this is one thing that could have
happened after this uh
idea but after bishop to c3 uh
polner actually played queen captures on
h3 right away which is
uh which is definitely more beautiful as
it uh sacrifices the queen not once but
twice uh because now of course uh you
either
capture and then we get the exact same
checkmate that we saw an ig for checking
h1 and
rook to h2 checkmate or we see
the one we still haven't seen queen
captures on h3
bishop actually captures the queen uh so
we just showed that one uh sorry a king
to g1
and now comes the second pattern queen
to
h1 check another offer of the queen and
this one you simply cannot decline
so bishop captures an h1 has to be
played and now a beautiful discovery
knight to h3 a double check which also
means
checkmate the king has nowhere to go the
rook controls the entire second rank and
it's uh
one of the one of the well definitely
one of the most beautiful games
ever played as it is against a future
world champion against a
fairly unknown gentleman uh sergey
ivanovich palmer
so a few more a few more words uh about
sergey like i said
i will put a link in the description
below so you can read a lot more about
him
as he does appear to be very strong so
sergey ivanovich although still very
young has long been considered one of
the best russian players
caution and correctness of the game
sometimes not devoid of wit
are the distinctive properties of his
style with more time spent on studying
the theory of the game
palmer will undoubtedly strengthen even
more and can become a worthy rival
of the first chess luminaries of all
countries uh
at the same time when a new rival just
to the still undeniable champion of
russia
mikhail ivanovich chigorin is growing in
his homeland
the latter has to fight again overseas
in distant havana against
wilhelm steinitz uh as you know uh who
uh
who who who challenged stein it's uh
some three years after this game was
played
uh but yeah it's it's very interesting
that at the time that
um someone else was the was the
strongest player in russia
uh mr mr palmer here crushes immanuel
asker like this so
uh i i thought it was very impressive
and i thought uh you guys
would enjoy such a game so uh let's just
see that one more time is it's not
something we see every day
so bishop c3 perfectly normal move uh
and then comes
queen captures on h3 just uh amazing
stuff
king g1 queen h1 check it's forced a
knight a bishop captures n knight to g4
sorry knights to h3 a beautiful
discovery now
it has to be a double check uh so yeah
uh that's uh the game i do hope you guys
enjoyed it uh
i was really really happy when i found
this game again
as like i said i was uh familiar with
this game i knew
uh knew the final position the the
combination that leads to this but i
never knew anything about paulner here
uh so i'm very happy that uh i i learned
a little bit about him and if you guys
uh are interested in that like i said
the first link in the description below
so uh i would like to thank a wise man
francois juan
jason boverman scott christiansen and
rohan donna for contribution
to my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and
i will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the morphe saga
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day